Elon Musk is upsetting millions of
Twitter users this weekend the
billionaire announced temporary
limitations on how many posts a user can
see on the media platform verified
account holders those who pay for their
blue checks are limited to reading only
10 000 posts a day unverified accounts
are capped at a thousand posts and new
unverified accounts are tapped at five
are topped off at 500 points Elon says
this is a way to fight artificial
intelligence companies from quote
extreme levels of data scraping but
folks are Furious Judge Jeanine are you
Furious extreme levels of data scraping
I don't know what that means I don't I
don't know what that means yeah uh yeah
yeah but you know look he's not the
government he's big business he I don't
know what his motivation is uh there's
something else going on here there's
definitely something else going on I
don't understand it but I have First
Amendment concerns but as I said he's a
private company he can do whatever the
hell he wants oh sorry he could do
whatever he wants
um you know and why is he so concerned
about you shouldn't be able to read more
than a thousand if he wants to make more
money with blue checks I get that but if
he's worried about people being too
connected to Twitter you know then he's
being like a national Twitter doctor I
mean we don't need it he said go outside
he did he tweeted yeah everyone go
outside have a good time I like his
light attitude he's the richest guy in
the world he sends uh spaceships out
into outer space and he seems to be
trying things out with 12 I don't know
what he's doing but he makes mistakes
and then he says sorry guys that didn't
work out so you you know I like that
he's experimenting this is what you know
these high-tech billionaires do I I like
that it's all out in the open and I do
love Twitter in the morning I make my
coffee I open up Twitter I see what's
going on are you a subscriber I did I
paid the subscription because I got you
yeah
that's why you don't care right
now to the judge's Point like there's
clearly something wrong in the
buttermilk what do you think is
happening at the Twitter headquarters
well he is a true Visionary and an
entrepreneur but and he engages directly
with people on Twitter about Twitter I
mean what how many people in the c-suite
ever do that they're always hiding
behind other folks look to me I would
call it the Fresh Air with friends and
family act by Elon Musk he's basically
saying to everybody put that darn thing
down and go get some fresh air why don't
you live offline a little bit this is
important because I'm still sitting here
just mathematically physically trying to
figure out how you can possibly view ten
thousand posts in a day and function
otherwise is human being this happened
on a Saturday morning in the month of
July before the Fourth of July holiday
and people were losing their minds and
really what it was it was the greatest
troll of all time to let us know we're
spending way too much time caring about
what people who don't matter think are
you a subscriber to this no okay I've
got two little prosthetic legs next to
my name would you say fresh air family
and friends Fresh Air with friends and
family act yes Fresh Air with friends
on Twitter hi winner Brian Kilmeade I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now